Leonardo DiCaprio is living his best
life yes the Titanic star was spotted
ringing in the new year overseas as he
was pictured on a yacht off the coast of
Saint Barth alongside a few friends the
48 year old is seen taking in the sights
on board with friend Joseph naumann and
his fiancee Madison Hedrick along with
another unidentified woman
as we know one of Hollywood's most
eligible bachelors is reportedly still
on the market after Calling it Quits
with model and actress Camilla Marone
back in August
during their four years together the
pair raised some eyebrows over their
22-year age Gap many critics pointed out
that now 48 year old rarely dates women
over the age of 25. meanwhile in the
time since their breakup Leo has been
linked with 27 year old model Gigi Hadid
A source told people back in September
that Leo is taken with Gigi while adding
Hadid is the type of woman he is usually
attracted to however the pair were last
spotted together back in November while
having dinner in New York as for Leo's
rumored New Flame the actor is
reportedly spending some time with
actress Victoria llamas with her dad
telling the New York post that she is
very smitten adding I know she likes him
very much I think they met last month
I'm not sure of the circumstances but
that's what she told me